uhoh manic energy entering the New Year
anyone else feel displaced and equally
as excited about possibility as they are
scared
about everything first Vlog of 2024 it's
a hodge podge to say the least I am a
wishy-washy little at the
beginning of this year have all these
oscillating feelings about productivity
and making and then like outing
myself and all this old mean selft talk
I vlogged some and then I stopped
vlogging and then did Vlog again and so
here's some hodge podge pieces hello I
look a bit Corps likee it's I think
maybe the breast cancer which I guess
what don't have
anymore have I vlogged no I haven't I
haven't vlogged I've instagrammed about
this we went to the doctor last week I
have no concept of time I had a
lumpectomy after lumpectomy went to the
doctor which happened after I posted the
last video I posted and we found out
that I've had a complete response to the
treatment Elliot and I went to the
surgical doctor's office today for our
followup after surgery to find out what
the results of surgery were and she said
the results were perfect and the best
that they could have hoped for that I've
had a complete response and that there's
no evidence of cancer
anymore and I'm
like so
overwhelmed I like I'm in shock and so I
get cleared now to move on to radiation
and hormone therapy if I did not get a
complete response I would have had 14
rounds of chemo to do we're very
thankful for the complete response we're
also thankful for whatever skin
smoothing filter this camera
automatically puts on my face because I
just walked on the treadmill for a
little bit which which is incredible
it's been 2 weeks since my surgery and
I'm able to walk on the treadmill a
little bit to gain some what's it called
I'm out of breath thinking what that
stamina is a word so sorry that arm's
tired I don't have a I don't have a God
the brain fog the brain fog tripod to
put you on the brain has not had a
complete response it's exciting news all
around hasn't fully set in it's all very
surreal I will process it as it settles
more I still feel very much in a fever
dream but the other big news is that
tomorrow Elliot and I are going to San
Diego for a little outing that was part
of his Christmas present Elliot has told
me recently he wants to hold animals
that's like a thing he would enjoy doing
in his adult life his dream he told me
recently is like an African safari which
I didn't know did you know that about
Elliot I didn't know that about Elliott
we're not going to do that but I thought
a good first step is going to the zoo
also I haven't really traveled in a long
time so this is like a baby step in
traveling a little bit I'm so used to
being at home and so comfortable being
at home but I also really love traveling
I'm just a little wary of it right now
so this is like a good little step cuz
we can drive down there I got an Airbnb
we're only going for two nights and then
we're coming back I'll Vlog some of it I
asked him if it was okay to Vlog which
you know always to ask for consent um
and he said it was okay and then Elliot
and I took a super cute little trip to
San Diego where I got to test being
outside of my house
[Music]
hell
yeah incredible engineering oh God we
just got to our little Studio Airbnb
look how cute this place is boom boom
boom boom boom but I think I did a
really good job cuz look at this this
part
whoa auga auga that's a crazy ass
view she's a mechanic that goes to
dinner I'm going to Vlog he's going to
Vlog I'm going to Vlog okay I've already
said that you've given consent that I
can Vlog some of this trip doesn't make
me any less awkward and I apologize
we're going to go to dinner I'm out of
practice practice with going to dinner
went to dinner with mamar chip the other
night but we were high on the good news
that I didn't have cancer in my body so
this is a a dinner just us at a nice
place we'll be fine we'll be fine and no
one will think we're weird or strange
and we're dressed perfectly for a
dinner okay three two one
vlogging thanks hey everybody welcome
welcome backod Vlog good morning look at
this crazy view to wake up to look at
that can you see the ocean wow I'm
getting really good at putting my
fingers in the frame as I hold the
camera in the year of 2024 as we travel
we have become people that I didn't ever
think we become let me show you happy
happy also we have become people that
travel to an Airbnb with their blender
to make their smoothies in the morning I
brought all of our smoothie making items
cuz we've been making smoothies every
morning and I thought let's bring it to
the Airbnb and make smoothies in the
Airbnb what do you make of that look at
this camera angle this is the perfect
camera angle for both of us I'm going to
make a smoothies cuz that's how we wake
up in the morning now this is beautiful
smoothie and animals oh we've become so
PG wholesome plays this video game
immediately
[Music]
Yum Yum Yum look at
this cool we're on our way to the San
Diego Zoo it's 10:18 a.m. honestly I'm
so proud that look at us up and Adam I
feel like I am dressed for a school
field trip right now we're going to go
see the animals Elliott's already made a
bit of a plan which all I remember is
elephants first no oh they are on there
yet but it's gonna they just show you
the map based some of the animals you
would like to see but there's so many
let's go to the zoo look at this
excellent Vlog almostly almost call it
like an ordinary adventure oh boy quite
ironic in hindsight that my first trip
in the real world out of my own little
home enclosure was to a zoo Elliot
wanted to see animals I wanted to take
them to the zoo zoos are very polarizing
for people most mostly because of the
bears polar bears get
it and I vlogged a bunch of stuff at the
zoo and then I was like zoos are not
everyone's favorite thing I understand
the moral issue with animals and cages
and I did some research about it I read
this blog post that someone put up about
trying to find out whether their own
trip to the San Diego Zoo was ethical
and they made some great points about
the zoos of credibility and some of the
work that they site that they're
actually doing for endangered species to
me is good I wrote about this on patreon
which if you're not a member of the this
might get we patreon you should be
because every Friday I write little
sappy like stream of Consciousness diary
entries over there and this last week I
wrote about the trip to the zoo and you
can read more about the incredible
mythical magical experience that we
encountered with an orangutang and an
old woman in a wheelchair a profound
little moment oh hello are you in here
ell came inside the house and I lost my
momentum where was I Zeo I don't even
know people regardless of the moral
dilemma that a zoo provokes in people I
don't even know if people want to watch
footage of being at a zoo the whole time
I was filming at the zoo I was like I'm
not very good at this filming thing
anymore so here's look we'll make
something to that
[Music]
boom we came in and I had instant
sensory overload so now we're walking
getting away from everybody towards I
think elephants we might be walking back
back to the parking lot we're not
[Music]
sure it's all right buddy it's okay it's
okay I get
[Music]
it
[Applause]
this is truly has to be the worst camera
work I've done all
day what a day what a day
huh how many stars going back to our car
now we got fudge on the way out a
perfect end and cookies and cookies hey
whoa sorry I didn't know I didn't mean
anything hey I was staying here cuz
Elliot thinks that this jacket I got at
Target on the way down cuz I forgot ack
it makes me look like a narc and he's
not wrong that you guys have any grass
we're going to go eat Italian food now
look how comfortable and cool she is I
didn't record anything at dinner we came
back I put a sweatshirt on and now we're
watching
Ratatouille no I haven't seen it again
excellent vlogging excellent angles
excellent content I'm eating Oreos yes
I'm just trying to block don't show me
eting Oreos I know I'm trying to block
out him eating Oreos okay a great end to
a beautiful time in San Diego
go no then we came back and we're in
this awkward part of the New Year where
I have all of these thoughts and ideas
about uh the ways I want to be better
I'm really scattered lately is anyone
else feeling scattered I feel
particularly scattered tomorrow I meet
with my radiologist for the very first
time and I will find out what my
radiation schedule will be so again I'm
in a little bit of a holding pattern in
this current moment right now as I'm
filming this I guess it's about finding
a rhythm I feel a bit offbeat right now
for a woman adult that has never had
natural rhythm in her life it is a bit
harder to try find a rhythm but I'd like
to try and find a rhythm this year I
have a lot of writing I want to do and I
avoid starting writing because I think
about the magnitude of the projects as a
whole rather than just diving into the
beginning bits are you going to eat your
bone right now right here with the the
noise of chewing a bone while I'm
filming probably aren't you can we take
this in the living room you see it's
very difficult to find a rhythm oh I
wanted to show you about the book too
let me get that okay so so a few things
happen ghost come on my girl so a few
things going on this month one I'd like
to commit to a writing schedule trying
to write an hour a day regardless of
quality of writing and I think I might
try to document that you know document
writing ising thrilling but I feel like
I might honor my accountability more in
some way if I try to document the
process of writing regularly I don't
know I'm just going to we're going to
figure that out we are falling forward
into our ideas this year maybe there's
some system in which we all write
together if you also want to commit to a
daily practice of something whether
that's writing or meditating or
exercising or cooking or reading or
whatever or arting whatever that might
be for you I haven't figured out past
the idea of just wanting to tell you
that I want to write an hour a day and
is there a world in which we do that
together what does that look like
throwing that out there let me know what
your thoughts are on that and maybe we
can figure something out I don't know
the other thing boom this book
remarkably bright creatures I am reading
it why is it so thick because it's the
large print edition look at that so easy
to read that this might get weird
patreon we have like a loose book club
called barflies bar are standing for bad
at reading mry came up with it obviously
we switch off each month choosing a book
and I've have chosen remarkably bright
creatures which is recommended by one of
our patrons I haven't read a fiction
book in I have no idea how long I
started it last night that's as far as I
made it if you have any interests sign
up for our patreon Sunday January 28th
I'm doing a live stream at 2 pm. Pacific
time where we are going to meet and talk
about this little book big book large
book large print edition ooh we love
that link in the description if you want
to sign up for the this mik get Weir
patreon what else was I going to tell
you about I went grocery shopping this
morning that was a success life hack go
grocery shopping at 9:00 a.m. on a
Sunday not many people there the
rotisserie chickens aren't even out yet
that was the only downside I want to do
more cooking videos because I want to
focus on healthier versions of food and
healthy recipes in general
so that's what I want to do you got to
put it out there right making it real
manif festing and whatever that is I
also want to just make more videos in
general and potentially try to upload
every week we'll see everything's Loosey
Goosey right now a lot of things will
get figured out based on this meeting
with our Radiologists I believe I hope
so I think I'm going to end this video
here but hello 2024 very excited to be
here have a lot of potentialities of
things going on feeling physically
better than I have in so long I'm sure
there will be some side effects from
radiation but man I I
am almost astonished at how good I feel
my brain fog seems to be lifting a
little bit I don't feel constantly like
I'm in a fever dream I feel only a
little bit like I'm in a fever dream
also let me know if there are any other
cancer related specific type of videos
that you guys would be interested in I
think someone that mentioned before like
can you show all of your favorite
products and things that you've used
throughout the breast cancer treatment
process and I might try to gather up a
bunch of show that to you is out of
Interest otherwise I hope you guys have
had good starts to your year this was a
lot of open-ended vague talk ideas I'm
an idea woman my follow through is what
we need to follow through on so brain is
scattered again I think that's all I
wanted to talk to you about for now I'll
see you in the next video Rhythm we're
finding the Rhythm other than that I
don't know I don't I don't know I need
to wrap this up I need this this needs
to end